the election for Alabama's open Senate
seat takes place tomorrow between
Democrat Doug Jones and controversial
Republican Roy Moore now this is a very
competitive race President Trump has
endorsed Roy Moore a lot of people upset
about that well now president obama has
lent his support to doug jones in fact
in an effort to stop Trump and more
former President Obama recorded a robo
call on behalf of Doug Jones yeah and it
just went out we got a hold of it we're
the only show that has it Barack Obama
and I urge you to get out and support
Doug Jones for US Senate Doug Jones is a
fighter for equality progress
don't let you do it but I thank you how
are you hacking into my robo calls Iraq
believe me this is nothing
Vladimir said guys are incredible I
watched Margot Robbie eat breakfast is
boarding that's illegal now Donald get
out of my home payback's a right
wiretapper duh come on stop supporting
Doug Jones why can't you just sit this
one out it's too important why do you
care man when I'm done being president
all I'm gonna do is tweet eat fast food
and go how is that different from what
you're doing now you son of a
[Applause]
you